So, what is computer architecture. Architecture, in the sense that
we all know it, is about designing a building that
is well suited for its purpose. So, it could be
designing, for example, an apartment building or a house and
what we want is for this building to be designed
so that it work wells for whatever you want to
use it. Like, for a family to live in or
for a lot of people to live in. Or if it's
an office building, for a lot of offices to
be there and the employees to be happy and
so on. So, computer architecture is similar in that
it is about designing a computer this time that
is well suited for its purpose. So, we can
have a large desktop computer, or a much smaller
laptop computer. Or even a smartphone. And we want
to design each of these so that they work well.
Maybe the desktop, because it's larger, can
be much more powerful. The laptop provides
some computational power in a much more
constrained space. And the phone provides us with
a good battery life and it's very light weight and still provides us with
some computational power that is enough to,
for example, do web browsing and so on.